ich bin so eine später sieht man einfach
komplett reset schalter mein internet
jola da was geht ab hier ist euer kran
ii und wir spielen heute mal wieder ein
ründchen war
lasst uns auf dem server ging bis drei
jahre aktiv ist schon da und haben
jedoch nicht locker ein
ja immer noch aus italien heute mit
einem bisschen besseren ton wenn es geht
weil ich hab jetzt dieses schöne
mikrofon schau dort an simon der das
provisorisch geflickt hat die ming
aldrin sie morgen nach getrennt nein die
wahlfreiheit da du bewegst dich nicht
mehr
diese bewegten ich will du bewegst ich
bin jetzt wirklich bei mir essen mit ich
leg des todes
ja ich glaube ich als dürftig ist es
dürfte jetzt funktionieren nicht dass
ihr das gesehen haben und jetzt hier
direkt gar nicht wo wir sind wir stimmen
heute mal wieder sehr chaotisch aber
schaffte almeida jetzt geht alles
flüssig richtung spawn okay das lag
immer noch ein bisschen aber eigentlich
habe ich 18 mb ab und vier anbieter also
was würdest du natürlich noch etwas
verdeckt egal
wir sammeln hühner oder hühner machen
können dazu gelernt wie man schießt und
wie heute wer ist heute gestorben
ich war irgendwie alles wird noch stand
habe ich so darunter gesehen man jetzt
ist für mich ein genaueres jetzt ist war
auf mich gelaufen nur noch teams teil
die sich alle viel zu ernst nehmen und
oder kennt ihr noch jemanden der der
auch nur so scheiße baut nicht einmal
viel geschrieben team zum dato oder
tornado anhalt und team gefeiert
der team er sowieso alter was wollen die
gegend viel mehr machen ich hatte ihm
reden niemand ernst hat die ganze zeit
meinen laptop auf energiesparmodus also
wenn ihr gerade kleine lecks hatte beim
zuschauer eine schritt auf
höchstleistung und du merkst auch schon
direkt müssten weniger vorsicht alex
hier gibt es irgendwie keine münchen
halle oder was wir müssen auf jeden fall
hier lang
denn der 200 oder der arme hat lässt es
einer in der kombi nachgefolgt
schippmann wenn wir jetzt welche sehen
es wäre richtig rollt wir werden ich
sagte werden welche sehen krankhafter
zwei von fünf balken bei teplice von ja
so bist du ja werden hunderte von lange
nicht ein bisschen defensiver spielen
und irgendwie ja klar wir können ja mal
gucken ob da falls einer ist dann gehen
wir weg war luden blume gekickt sehr
schön sehr schön um gold
ok wären die anderen auch gekickt
ich hoffe es okay da ist holz gebaut ok
iams wochen brauchen wir ja immer
irgendwelche waren das erste mal wieder
an der oberfläche eigentlich oder so
wirklich
also schau mal wie viel hast du ich hab
zwei ich habe neun mal auf der wir auch
richtig gut lesen können achtung hier
hier ist allerdings gestorben wer sich
schon mal weit gestorben das hier doch
um tanzen sie zu demütigen
wer ist gestorben die münchner block
oder scott porter kilo gold ist ihr mal
ein wasser in lava einmal bereit hast du
glaub ich ein anlass einmal ist halt
wirklich sinnvolle m lg da war wenn du
sonst für ex ich so auch damit ihnen die
teams nicht retten oder private mit f3
kannst du ja schauen ob was das für
geschäft ist ja ja genau sollte immer
sein sollen wie ernst otto schäfer um
ball ist drin
kommt jetzt raus aber vergisst nein aus
dem portal
alter schwede sven pippig habe ich habe
der wilex wollen wir uns nicht entziehen
die kiste machen
einfach so damit nie mal reinschauen
darf vielleicht kriegen oder 30 mal eine
kiste machen also dass wir eine teams
haben halt dass sie abbauen und wenn wir
selbst ja okay dann stelle daneben habe
und ich mache dann stellt das ist
richtig dumm was wir hier machen anstatt
dass wir einfach
wir sollten anstatt dass wir einfach
weggehen und einfach wie es klingt es
unter unter der erde in die ganze zeit
farben und diese drei folgen regel
machen so dass man nicht getan werden
kann
die sich trennen wir einsparungen machen
wo steht man nicht einfach komplett
alter meine internet ist das so gut ich
weiß nicht was los ist du hast mich aber
noch nie ja leute die sind allerdings
weiß wo kriegt man da ist ein pigment
wir wollen wir reingehen in der luise
mathiaschitz du deinen sachen reinigung
nicht aus
durch die andere und dann mache ich
lustig ist von wählen ich werde
produzieren
zack zack wir nehmen sie sehr ernst
vielleicht können wir irgend jemanden
überreden dass wir im fernkampf aber es
liegen ja wohl schon typische ich jetzt
auch okay so du stehst du mir noch ein
portal wie ein stein vom herzen dass wir
machen hier da vorne ist es noch ein
bisschen
wir wollen ja wir wollten ja kurz farben
und damit halt level bekommen ich würde
halt oder ist netter fest direkt wurde
da gerade aus einfach das beste was drin
ich denke ich aber dass mario hinbauen
du dich vor weil bei mir weg durchlaufen
müssen oder wollen wir uns hier einfach
runter bauen oder wenn nicht dann
dollar zu stellen jetzt mach mal was den
penis auf der ich traute mich doch
gerade comics hoch mal wo bist du hast
du den blick überhaupt
ja ich habe den schon gebaut ohne dass
ich an jemals an dieser stelle war nicht
hast du das gemacht und schied mit auto
bild klicken
ja also wir sollten uns auf jeden fall
in köln machen
ja weil man sich in halle nicht löschen
kann aber mit dem colt und schon davon
machen was bitte schön wenn du musst
einfach nur wie eine hose noch anders
reisen machen die hellenen doch da liegt
er doch nicht immer muss man aufhören
erfüllt
du musst den hinsetzen wenn du brennst
und dann tust du da wasser rein mit aus
einem eimer raus und dann springst du
bist du gelöscht später springreiter
otto
vielleicht bringe alter da vorne ist
soviel quatsch dass die magneten
denn da vorne ich habe so angst dass
deswegen beim internet hört hier das
irgendwie ja das ist mal versteckt dass
ich es nicht konnte ich dann direkt in
der lage bin
weißt du wo du stehst bei mir der luft
und mein gott alter beifahrer mit
skeletten einfacher vorgang niemandem
angst diesem thema
ich habe höchstens angst vor wir nehmen
wir nehmen niemanden ernsthaft ihn
allerdings vom kopf lieber nicht
nein damit ist natürlich
ich glaube es nicht oder jetzt erstmal
ein bisschen bisschen quad fahren
ich habe halt immer noch vier level und
wir sehen verdanken dass wir keinen
links holt also nächste folge müssen wir
definitiv münchen oder münchen hätten
gestern morgen war die level flohr 1
bis zum morgen hin wir einfach töten ja
aber da ist es auch ziemlich gut
gegriffen
er ist auch einer lernst zu mindern
ein spaß ja natürlich so müsste morgen
von dem habe ich echt was wollt ihr mich
ich werde komplett behindert hier durch
die gegend getötet bei mir wegen beim
tracks internet das ist echt nicht mehr
schön auch lieber aus koppel dicker weil
holz verschwindet einfach weil wenn es
brennt an israel verstehen max ich fühle
mich nicht wohl das lieber wieder die
normale welt gehen und auf pussy machen
um zu sammeln aber erstmal in die decken
oder in die festung
ja ja so wie am zwei folgen alter das
danach denkt hier weg wieder
wir meinen natürlich daheim noch
trainieren sven kneipen wollt dann
bleiben wir noch hier kommt einfach
jeden wartet dann erfolge und dann aber
mein gamma hochgestellt gestern war das
echt besser weil gestern habe ich noch
mit meiner deutschen team aufgenommen
jetzt gerade nehme ich mit meiner world
der oft mit meiner italienischen und
hier in erster linie einfach bestens
gewählt aber hier mein absolutes mega
starker mann ein download also
hauptservers und davon gibt's noch den
spender ist abgebaut vor sich fast
allein vor sich wenn du zurück gestoßen
ist ein bisschen brot ich sehe da nicht
wird nicht am rand bewegen
vorsicht glätte [ __ ] deine anschrift
ich weiß ich weiß
vor allem ihr nur lax mit den toren zum
eben was ich tue vergibt nicht irgendwie
so mega behindert okay aber du musst
hier wieder den koordinator spielen ich
habe absolut keinen plan
hast du jetzt eigentlich mein lover
einmal mittlerweile wäre vielleicht an
der zeit aber wir müssen uns mal ins
team machen ach nee die zuschauer haben
ja gesagt das verboten habe ich ganz
vergessen
ich verstehe ich nicht warum
die gesagt dass es geboten das safety
car ist nicht mehr hier wird schon alles
gelohnt jetzt kann sich jeder trenkmann
korrigiert egal ich habe einfach
ungefähr fünf sekunden verzögerungen bis
ich so eine schatzkiste aufmachen kann
das ist traurig alter wenn wir diese
folgen die in italien überleben
wir müssen nur noch einmal aufnehmen
wenn wir die folgen überleben leute dann
gäbe es nicht zwei bmw hält du hast du
bist ja der ok sich selbst allerdings
hat die pistazie gilt wird kommen ich
komme da unten ich war ja kein schwimmer
knapp den schmerz lindern
was du hier tue es weil ich es tun wobei
das aber investoren da bin ich kein bock
das hier drüber bauen ich bin 56 er bald
wieder irgendwie insider mit film ich
kann aber ich habe doch schon einmal
gesagt auch wir sind über 750 muss eins
runter um 46 das war steht ein level
clown richtig klasse 12 jetzt sechs
leute actionfilms trend irgend jemand
von euch unsere produktivität an
strahlend leitstelle in frage stellt an
streitet ist dann kommt vor wenn ich
zweifel toskana venedig am strand beim
täglichen das eins-gegen-eins 11
gamescom
ja ich sehe es schon so die kommentare
von diesen ganzen sie uns am anfang so
weit weil wir ein bisschen auf ich laufe
schnell noch zum festland verstand alter
dessen gast
alles okay du wurdest du alter kidman
erhitzt ihr okay und heute schon wieder
nur drei sekunden gedauert bis den
falschen bekommen
bei mir geht es die aufnahme auch gerade
zu ende ok